foreign
[Music]
thank you
are you ready for this
of course you are come on don't be shy a
little fancy suit impress you
don't let a thousand fancy suits impress
you
be the thorn in history science
choose the greatest enemies
the captain
sorry mate
the emperor
the boss's boss
and make even greater friends decent
work Leonardo
don't just pick a fight
start a revolution
get the bigger picture
go too far
go too fast
face the invisible
The Impossible
the Unspeakable
welcome to the greatest playground
history
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome along to the
first ever Assassin's Creed showcase it
is time to LEAP into history I'm Danny
Wallace here in our top secret hideout
where I'll be bringing you some sneak
peeks special guests and sharing some
very exciting updates on all things
Assassin's Creed you will not want to
miss this today I am joined by a true
expert Assassin's Creed's senior
community developer ubisoft's own Alice
turret welcome to the show Alice can you
believe it's been 15 years thank you so
much Dan Annie I cannot believe it's
been 15 years it's a series very close
to my heart because I'm in it I'm lucky
enough to voice Sean Hastings who first
appeared Back In Assassin's Creed II now
Sean sounds exactly like me which may
give you a clue as to the limits of my
acting range this year we are
celebrating 15 years since the release
of the first Assassin's Creed it's been
an amazing journey with our community
that started back on the rooftops of the
Holy Land it has taken us to the Italian
Renaissance into the center of
revolutionary Wars to ancient worlds and
to many incredible places in between
we've met Unforgettable characters and
been to breathtaking locations allowing
you to LEAP into history and relive
pivotal moments from our past it's been
a phenomenal 15 years and we are so glad
that you came along for the ride
for the 15-year anniversary of
Assassin's Creed we want to truly
celebrate with you our community we know
that you've been dying to find out
what's next for Assassin's Creed and so
uh just on that point it does sound a
lot like you're about to announce a new
game or something and I am about to
announce a new game I just thought it'd
be nice to see as I'm here so anyways uh
it's time to discover what we've been
crafting in the shadows I hope you
brought a trailer at least I have roll
the trailer
[Music]
foreign
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were I am
[Music]
[Applause]
ready to sacrifice everything you have
clothes I am
[Music]
are you ready to leave your life behind
and walk the path of Shadows
I am
[Music]
thank you
something
then out of the dark you will come into
the light
[Music]
[Music]
and from the light
you will return to the dark
thank you
[Music]
never forget the tenants you have sworn
to uphold
[Music]
stay your blade from the Flesh of the
innocent
[Music]
hide in plain sight
never compromise the Brotherhood
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
from this day forward
you are a hidden one
[Music]
foreign
Mirage everybody and here to tell us
more it is Ubisoft bordeaux's narrative
director Sarah paulier thank you so much
for coming thank you for having me Sarah
we just had a little glimpse of Mirage
what can you tell us about this latest
and very special Assassin's Creed
Adventure well indeed it is special we
go back to the roots of this series it's
been 50 years as you know and wanted to
go back to the action adventure game
that you know narrative driven game uh
we've been focusing on stealths for core
and of course assassinations
now I've been playing a lot of Valhalla
recently and from watching that trailer
I couldn't help but notice Basim yes
you're right it's passing it's 20 years
before Valhalla so it's a young Basim
there's gonna be coming from a street
Thief to a Master assassin oh fantastic
and and so where does his kind of
Adventure begin well it begins in
Baghdad uh it's the beautiful
magnificent
city of Baghdad that you're gonna roam
through the game and it's um yeah it's a
very dense City where you're going to
meet a lot of different people that's
amazing I know our community has been
very excited to explore Baghdad um so
Sarah what can you tell us that makes
Mirage special to you specifically what
to me obviously it's all about the story
so as you saw we have a couple of
charismatic characters
starting from the same so Basim is all
lead character we do have Russian that
you spotted in the trader she's basim's
Mentor we also have a lot of historical
characters like in every Assassin's
Creed so political leaders for example
but not not just we do have a couple of
very very interesting characters in
there but what a setting and what
history to get your teeth into but we're
obviously about exclusives here have you
got any more yes I do good and did you
recognize the voice from the trailer I
did actually can I can I can I reveal it
can I reveal it
it was the Emmy winning actress wasn't
it sorry AG Dash Lou it was it was yeah
you got it right good yeah we're
thrilled to have her in the cast She's
going to be portraying Russian so she's
going to be the voice of Mentor that you
send the trader actually and the whole
team is very very glad to have her she's
fantastic such a recognizable voice
which is why I recognize that of course
well and we were lucky enough to catch
up with Shorey earlier and she had this
very special message
hello everyone I am sorry when I'm
thrilled to announce that I will be
voicing Roshan that seems Mentor in
Assassin's Creed Mirage when Ubisoft
approached me to voice this character I
was immediately seduced by Roshan as a
strong personality and her backstory
she's a true warrior who fights for
justice
protects her fellow hidden ones at all
costs
she is loyal and honest but keep her
former self behind a shroud of Mystery
and of course the fact that she is a
mature woman from Persian Origins made
her resonate even more with my own story
and background
playing such a character is a unique
opportunity that I could not miss I hope
you will love her as much as I do it's a
real pleasure for me to collaborate with
the Assassin's Creed brand and play one
of the main characters in such an
anticipated new game
I am wishing you all a Happy AC 15th
anniversary
thank you all yours
sincerely sorry artist
what a nice message what a recognizable
voice as well just instantly and she
seems thrilled to be part of this yeah I
think she is really let's go to welcome
addition to the Assassin's Creed world
so finally obviously the question
everyone wants to know when can we get
our hands on Mirage assassin's marriage
is going to be available in 2023 and if
you pre-order now you also get the
exclusive 40 thieves side quests but
it's not all we also have a collector's
case available for pre-order as well it
includes a figurine of bassim and other
exclusive surprises that you will love
thank you Sarah for being with us today
thank you for having me thank you very
much yes it looks fantastic right we'll
be dropping more exclusive news from the
world of Assassin's Creed very shortly
but first we wanted to celebrate the
last 15 years of Assassin's Creed with
you let's remind ourselves of some of
the highlights and of course the impact
of this groundbreaking series
could you come into the light
from the light
you will return to the dark
[Music]
prepared to travel the Eagles path
welcome aboard it's prizes plunder and
Adventure ahead
[Music]
all different
but our great will unify us
[Music]
do you regret your decision to live as
an assassin for so long
foreign
this life
it chose me
what is the man but the sum of his
memory we are the stories we live the
tales we tell ourselves
gentlemen as his custom among Our Kind
we do not plunge headlong into Folly on
the orders of a single Madman but act
according to our own
Collective Madness
[Music]
from Darkness we have come and in
darkness we shall stay
we are the hidden ones
[Music]
it is a good life we live
foreign
[Music]
well so many memories there makes me
want to jump back in and just play
through the whole series again well
Danny to continue the celebrations we
also have a new documentary out today
which gives a behind the scenes look at
the last 15 years of Assassin's Creed
let's take a sneak peek
for me Assassin's Creed represents my
whole video game in the carrier
it's really like where I learn my job
where I grew in my job
that was really the game that showed to
me hey you gotta step it up but like you
gotta move on from the PS2 and I fell in
love ever since
Assassin's Creed especially in those
early days showing people what could be
done in this kind of broad open space
just like climbing up things and just
looking at this world and being like oh
wow I've never done this in a video game
before we're always looking for the next
Assassin's Creed no matter which one is
your favorite you'll always be tied to
it because of just how connected they've
kept you in from the beginning it's not
just the game it has a philosophy behind
it it's a universe it's not just a
single setting in a single time but it's
different settings at different times
it's like a narrative universe that
comes to life
[Music]
well that looks worth a watch to me
where can we see it is it somewhere on
the internet yes it will be on the
internet uh you can catch it on the
Ubisoft and GTV YouTube channels but
don't go anywhere just yet no so back to
business and I've just finished the dawn
of Ragnarok expansion for Assassin's
Creed Valhalla at a great time but I
would like some more yep that's one of
our most ambitious expansions today but
Danny if you want more I've got great
news as we have more content coming to
Assassin's Creed Valhalla
hello everyone I'm Gareth Glover game
director on Assassin's Creed by the
house post launch
since launch we've continued to create
new and exciting content for our
community to enjoy we've already
released new game modes and activities
into the world of Valhalla such as River
raids tombs of the Fallen Mastery
challenges and more recently the road
light forgotten Saga today I'm excited
to announce that in a few months time we
will also be launching the last chapter
so let's take an exclusive first look
[Music]
Odin
I feel you close
an opera of memories stretching far into
the past
I have done all I can for my people
it is time to say goodbye and set forth
for Distant Shores and new adventures
fascinating Ava grappled with Odin's
memories in a way unfamiliar to me
where will this new conflict take you I
wonder
foreign
which nicely ties up some of the
storylines established throughout the
game we'll see avor reunite with some
key characters including some
influential historical ones we can't
wait for you to experience it back to
you Danny and Alice
Danny are you ready for some more
exclusives no no I'm not no I'm a little
overwhelmed already but please go on
okay well our next guest can do just
that
stranger to the Assassin's Creed family
with a list of credits including
creative director of Assassin's Creed
Syndicate and producer of Assassin's
Creed Odyssey I'm of course talking
about Mark alexicote Mac thanks for
joining us well thank you Alice it's
great to be here and I I love what
you've done with the place thank you uh
so let's start with our community can
you tell us what makes Assassin's Creed
so beloved by our Global Community well
at Ubisoft our mission as a company as
expressed by Eve is to enrich the lives
of players on Assassin's Creed we have a
very clear take on that mission we want
history to be everybody's playground as
we immerse players into the richness of
our shared past what makes AC different
though is this kind of unique mix
between historical accuracy and
contemporary codes like the Animus and
when you put all that together it gives
you the chance to embody iconic
characters to live powerful fantasies
all the while immerse an intriguing
historical settings it's amazing so how
will Assassin's Creed evolve in the
coming years well we're going to double
down on our passion for history as we
explore the past with courage we
strongly believe that uh history can be
the most powerful and eye-opening source
of entertainment and our teams believe
that history can help us better
understand the world that we live in as
so many elements from the past still
resonate with our present but don't
worry we're going to keep telling Grand
epic stories so that viewers and players
alike can feel the vertigo that only
human history can bring I love the way
you talk about history and about using
history as a playground what an
incredible thing to be able to use
history in this in this way but what
does this mean for fans going forward
well we want our passion for history to
fuel the expansion of the franchise into
new territories so I'm very happy to
announce today our very first open world
Assassin's Creed game for mobile it will
feature all the iconic Assassin's Creed
gameplay but optimize for an experience
on touch controls and I just can't wait
to tell you more about the story and the
setting let's take a look at the trailer
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well look at that a brand new Assassin's
Creed game set in China it looks amazing
uh Matt can you tell us a little bit
more about the features well for the
first time in our open world games you
can create your own character you'll get
the chance to do things like parkour
Atop The Great Wall of China sneak
through bustling cities engage in
intense combat and discover the secrets
of vastness of ancient China
well that leads me to my next question
so Mac many of us know that a Netflix
show is in development and the community
would like to know more what else can
you tell us well it's still early in
development but I can confirm that we
are co-developing the Netflix series
with Ubisoft film and television Netflix
obviously and an insanely talented
showrunner Jeb Stewart it's going to be
an epic jar bending a live-action
adaptation of our video game series but
that's not the only thing we have in
development with Netflix we also have a
new mobile game and development for
their platform wow so you're doing quite
a lot with Netflix and just out of
Interest there's no reason for me to ask
this this is just just curious a lot of
people probably want to know who who is
the casting director for that
why do you want to know no I'm just just
that a lot of people have been uh
tweeting in about that well we'll put
this name on screen I'll talk to you
after about that in the meantime let's
take a look at the wider world of
Assassin's Creed
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world of Assassin's Creed there and look
we've had a lot of surprises today I
think that's fair to say but in the
grand tradition of surprises Mack I
think you might have saved the biggest
one for last well Danny that's right
believe it or not I've got more things
to show to you so how about we take a
leap of faith into the future together
let's take a look
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I mean there's a lot of stuff in there
that I think from your point of view
certainly the community the fans have
been asking for for a long time so Mac
tell us more well this is code name red
our next premium Flagship title and the
future of our open world RPG games on
Assassin's Creed it is being developed
by Ubisoft Quebec the studio behind
Assassin's Creed Odyssey under the
creative direction of janatan sumo it
will let players explore one of their
most awaited settings ever on the
franchise feudal Japan and they live a
very powerful Shinobi fantasy I mean
people have been waiting for this for a
long time haven't they yes they have
they certainly have now you brought it
to them it's amazing which is good and
you're slightly cruel in that you're
teasing me with it I very much want that
you mentioned some of the other Studios
uh what's Montreal up to right now well
we have our veteran team behind
assassin's Creed Valhalla in Montreal
the birthplace of Assassin's Creed who's
been hard at work on a new flagship
title as well it is being led by a
creative director Clint Hawking and is a
very different type of Assassin's Creed
game and I believe you may have brought
us something that we can watch now yes
here it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS just keep on coming what can you
tell us about this project well this is
codename hexay and I can't wait for our
fans to tear apart that trailer and find
out all its Secrets yeah absolutely and
work out the code now you guys have
always got code names for stuff that was
um was it a year ago there was code name
Infinity where are you with that well
that's a great question Danny and I'm
happy to give you a little bit more
about project Infinity uh today Infinity
is not a game per se is going to be the
single entry point for our fans into the
Assassin's Creed franchise into the
future so are you saying that players
will be able to explore their very own
animus kind of like a time machine
exactly Alice Infinity is going to be a
hub that will unite all our different
experiences and our players together in
meaningful ways
so obviously that begs the question if
you're connecting players and there's
more than one player a lot of people
will be thinking are we talking
multiplayer well Danny it seems we can't
hide anything from you we're actually
investigating how uh we will bring back
Standalone multiplayer experiences into
the Assassin's Creed Universe all
connected to the infinity Hub well it
sounds extraordinary you must have a nap
at some point because you've all been
very very busy so our thanks Mac some
major new developments there and I'm
sure everyone at home can't wait to get
involved
um thank you for joining us today and
sharing all this incredibly exciting
news well thank you Danny thank you
Alice it's been a pleasure to be here
and to be finally able to share all
these great things that we have coming
for our fans
so to sum up there are a lot of exciting
things to look forward to Let's remind
ourselves of everything you can expect
from now onwards this year we will see
the release of the last chapter to
Abel's story in Assassin's Creed
Valhalla then in 2023 we'll see the
release of the next big title Assassin's
Creed Mirage set in Baghdad and
following the story of Basim from Street
Thief to master assassin
then it's time for the long-awaited
setting of feudal Japan with Assassin's
Creed codename red and as Mac announced
there will also be a very different type
of experience with Assassin's Creed
codename hexay and in the coming years
we'll see the launch of the new platform
Assassin's Creed Infinity connecting
players to the games in a whole new way
but that's not all we'll also see the
launch of our first open world game for
mobile with Assassin's Creed code name
Jade and of course the release of our
live-action Series in partnership with
Netflix so loads to come but that my
friends I'm afraid is all we have time
for today in this very special
Assassin's Creed anniversary showcase
now before I get too comfortable in our
Hideout and end up slipping into my Ezio
cosplay as normal I just want to thank
everyone for joining us today and making
this first ever showcase so special plus
of course a big thank you to our guests
and I shouldn't do this Alice but you
know in the spirit of wrapping up what's
the one thing you're most looking
forward to that's a very tricky question
we've seen so many amazing things
um I'm gonna pick a few okay I will
choose my Mirage the Netflix series and
also feudal Japan is that okay that's
fine great and for all of you at home
remember that you can pre-order Mirage
now in the meantime you can jump back
into Valhalla to prepare for Evil's last
chapter which is exactly Alice what I'm
going to do while we pass back to
Ubisoft forward we will see you next
time bye-bye goodbye
thank you